vamos a la revista de prensa y abrimos
el día de hoy en Estados Unidos porque
este domingo el vicepresidente de Max
spenso ofreció una entrevista exclusiva
a la cadena ABC news en la que criticó
la gestión de Donald Trump durante el
asalto violento al Capitolio del pasado
6 de enero del 2021 para hablar sobre
este tema y lo que dejó esa entrevista
está conmigo Marta Moya con todos los
detalles Marta Buen día para ustedes
Buenos días Ángela vamos a empezar con
esta entrevista hemos rescatado un
fragmento es en el programa World news
Tonight de la ABC news que presenta
David y es importante este fragmento
televisivo sobre todo por el silencio
del ex vicepresidente Mike pence
hablando de aquel día no de aquel 6 de
enero de 2021 cuando se produjo ese
asalto violento al Capitolio y estas
fueron las palabras del ex
vicepresidente veamos
los diputados estaban atrincherados en
el hemiciclo de la cámara
y en medio de todo usted pudo ver lo que
el presidente había tuiteado
a las 2:24 de la tarde el presidente
tuitea Mike pence no tuvo el coraje de
hacer lo que debía haber hecho
me enfureció
pero me dirigí a mi hija que estaba
parada a mi lado y le dije se necesita
valor para romper la ley
se necesita valor para defender la ley
quiero decir las palabras del presidente
fueron imprudentes
muy bien Vamos a continuar hablando de
esta nación norteamericana Pero ahora
con el final show Times que publicó un
artículo de análisis sobre los datos son
más relevantes después de las elecciones
de medio término Marta que dicen Sí
vamos a destacar seis claves de este
artículo del final Times que dice lo que
hemos aprendido de las elecciones de
medio término la clave número uno es que
si los republicanos como todo parece
indicar terminan controlando la cámara
de representantes con una mayoría exigua
significaría que los demócratas van a
tener la menor pérdida de escaños en
mucho tiempo y es que solo en 1986
1998 y 2002 los presidentes en ejercicio
obtuvieron mejores resultados en las
elecciones de medio término que las
presidenciales Eso sí los tres
presidentes de aquellas elecciones
tenían una aprobación del 60%, y vaiden
está en torno al 40 la segunda clave que
dice este que destaca este artículo del
Five Nights altimes es que el desempeño
demócrata donaciones y cámaras estatales
ha sido muy bueno han conseguido incluso
recuperar mantener las que ya tenían y
arrebatarles dos cámaras legislativas a
los republicanos y perdón 4 cámaras
legislativas a los republicanos y dos
gobernaciones la clave número 3 Es que
solo un candidato que
obtuvo el apoyo explícito de Donald
Trump ha conseguido obtener el escaño en
el senado Y aunque muchos candidatos
protrampistas han ganado lo han hecho en
distritos meramente republicanos la
cuarta clave es que los republicanos
mantienen más de El 90% de los escaños
en áreas Rurales y los demócratas más
del 90% de los escaños en áreas urbanas
la clave número 5 es que más de una
cuarta parte de los jóvenes entre 18 y
29 años han votado en estas elecciones
que supone la participación la segunda
participación más alta desde que hay
registros y la clave número 6 es que son
las elecciones de medio término donde se
ha empleado más dinero Bueno Marta muy
interesante y unas elecciones de las que
todavía seguimos esperando algunos
resultados vamos a cambiar de tema este
domingo tuvo lugar en España una
importante manifestación en Madrid en la
capital del país miles de personas
salieron a la calle a protestar por el
tema de la sanidad después de políticas
Ultra liberales de la presidenta de esa
región vamos a comenzar hablando de cómo
lo publica el diario.es sí Ángela
concretamente destacamos tres medios
empezamos por el diario punto es que
titula cientos de miles de personas
toman las calles de Madrid frente al
maltrato de Ayuso a la sanidad pública
Ayuso es Isabel Díaz Ayuso la presidenta
de la comunidad de Madrid que ha
impulsado políticas neoliberales para
hacer frente a la sanidad pública que
quiere desmantelar impulsando o
aumentando el gasto en la sanidad
privada No ella impulsó una política
Para volver a abrir los centros de
atención extra hospitalaria sin embargo
desde que se planteó esta medida a
finales de octubre Porque estos centros
llevaban cerrados desde la pandemia ha
habido un caos generalizado faltan
médicos se han mandado emails a
medianoche al personal para que acudan a
sus puestos de trabajo incluso a más de
60 kilómetros de sus lugares de
residencia No hay margen de acción para
estos sanitarios y esto ha motivado que
al menos 200.000 personas salieran a las
calles ayer en Madrid según los
organizadores más de 650.000 como
siempre varían las cifras según la
fuente y bueno todo se
resume en que piden más asistencia
personal
incrementación en el presupuesto de la
atención primaria no que es a donde
acuden los pacientes en este primer
intervalo antes de acudir o no a un
hospital que se aumenten las plantillas
y que por supuesto se deroguen las leyes
que permiten la privatización de la
sanidad también habla sobre del país el
país hace una columna de análisis de
Pablo Simón que titula batas blancas en
pie de guerra en España la sanidad está
cedida el control de la sanidad no las
competencias están cedidas a las
comunidades autónomas Por tanto la
presidenta de la comunidad de Madrid o
Los Seguidores del partido popular que
es este partido conservador que gobierna
en esa región no pueden echarle la culpa
del actual situación de la sanidad al
gobierno central no entonces la
estrategia del partido popular ha sido
demonizar a estas personas que han
salido a las calles y sostiene esta
columna del diario El País que es una
mala estrategia Porque además la
presidenta de la comunidad de Madrid
podría presentarse a las elecciones
generales del próximo año muy
rápidamente La Vanguardia La Vanguardia
titula también en una columna de opinión
sanidad low cost dice que la comisión
europea en 2014 pidió un incremento de
los recursos públicos en cuestiones de
sanidad por la necesidad de bueno por el
envejecimiento de la población
el incremento de las enfermedades
crónicas la demanda de servicios de
calidad y además el alto costo de los
avances tecnológicos Madrid es una de
las comunidades que menor invierten
sanidad y además de las que se jacta de
tener la presión fiscal más baja ahora
Marta aparece
el médico el medio británico de Garden
Sí hablamos de la Cup y el cambio
climático No espera mientras los líderes
mundiales se reúnen en Egipto hemos
destacado esta fotogalería donde vemos
por ejemplo La amenaza a las poblaciones
en Groenlandia por el deshielo en las
tormentas de arena en Australia una
familia aferrándose aferrándose a la
vida por un incendio forestal en
Tasmania La ola de calor sin precedentes
en China es de 2022 las inundaciones en
Pakistán que afectaron a más de 33
millones de personas o jirafas muertas
en Kenia por la sed pues mire Muchas
gracias a usted Marta por la
actualización invitados nuestros
televidentes a ahondar más en esta
debería de The Guardian él es un feliz
día y vamos con el invitado del día
gracias